and this what's he doing yes to go even
further beyond we train because we want
to keep getting better we want to keep
getting stronger you want to go even
further beyond and that's why it sucks
so much when you plateau when you hit
that ceiling and you can't go any
further your progress is denied
fortunately this is just an opportunity
to test your mettle and to push yourself
even harder and there are plenty of ways
that you can break through those limits
if you know how in this video we're
going to explore some of the best
okay so the first way that you can break
through a plateau smash those
limitations is to try micro plating so
micro plating basically means that
you're using tiny weights like this this
is a naught point 5 kilogram weight and
the idea is let's say that you're
performing a bench press and the maximum
1 rep max that you can perform is 140
then why pick that number to start with
the air you really want to be able to do
150 kilograms this is so what do you do
well with micro plating you add say one
kilogram onto the total and then you
perform your 1 rep max which would be
the 140 but now it's 141 you're never
going to notice that one kilogram
add it to the weight so it's fine and
then next we could go back to the gym
and on text day you perform another one
rep max this time 1 for 2 and then 1 for
3 you get the idea basically you're
increasing the weight in such small
increments that you don't notice them
but over time they of course all add up
and eventually before you know it you're
doing 150 kilograms you can actually use
an incremental increase months like this
in all kinds of other situations as well
the famous Milgram study in psychology
looked at how you can convince someone
to do something awful by just pushing
that line a little bit further back they
got people to electrocute participants
in this study by slightly increasing the
amount of the shock they were delivering
likewise allegedly the myth goes that
ninjas would learn to jump as high as
they would by jumping over dandelions
they to plant the dandelion I think that
aligns the right one I'm not a
horticultural expert they plant these
plants in the ground and then they jump
over them and then the next day they
jump over them again etc etc and
gradually the plant would grow and I
think if it's dandelions these plants
grow pretty high so before they knew it
they were leaping super high but every
day they'd only had to jump not even a
millimeter higher than the day before
and that way once again it can slowly
improve their technique and jump higher
and higher ok and technique number two
is going to involve my boy overcoming
metrics and another technique called
post activation principle so post
activation principle tells us that after
you've just recruited two muscles after
you've just lifted something heavy your
muscle fibers are then more potentiated
more easily excited and that way you can
recruit them more easily you can
increase your muscle fiber recruitment
so let's say you on the bench press
you've just done 140 kilograms and then
you drop down to a hundred kilograms
about a hundred kilograms now is gonna
feel very easy that's because you're
used to performing a hundred and forty
kilograms and comparatively a hundred is
very light and what's actually going on
here inside the muscles is that they're
more easily activated more easily
engaged but could you've just used them
so remember overcoming isometrics means
that you're using your maximum force
against an immovable object so that
might mean pushing against the wall or
pulling against the bar and this way
you're using your strongest contraction
the maximum possible amount of time and
what you're going to do in this case is
say you're doing the benchpress you'll
push against a wall as hard as you can
for about four seconds that's going to
be long enough to excite and engage
those muscle fibers but not long enough
to fatigue yourself then you're gonna go
straight to the benchpress and perform
your one rep max and you should find
that it's much more easy to recruit
those muscle fibres and hopefully smash
that limitation of course there many
other ways you can use the post
activation principle for instance just
doing warm-up sets can help you to build
those neural pathways and also enforce
your technique prior to trying one rep
max technique number three so for
technique number three we're gonna be
looking at focusing on the muscles that
might be letting you down and this might
include muscles that you hadn't thought
of so obviously the benchpress involves
the pecs the shoulders the triceps it
also involves the serratus muscles which
you might not have thought to train also
involves the core and even the legs if
you plant your feet on the floor so look
at what might be holding you back
likewise what's often holding you back
is grip strength grip strength is the
weak link in many people's training and
if you don't have the strongest quick
possible then you're gonna find that
your grip fatigues and this tires you
out and also you start to worry you're
going to drop the weight on yourself and
you have to put it down even if you had
more energy left in the tank so work on
your grip train that add that to your
routine and you should find that every
single lift improves another tip is to
contract your entire body during the
exercise and this
to tighten that kinetic chain and make
sure you're not losing any energy
anywhere so when you do the bench press
even though you might not think who
using your abs tense them contract
everything and that way you should have
more muscle control and you're putting
more energy into that bench press
symmetry is also important so this means
you need to have the same strength on
either side of your body in the bench
press in particular it's very easy to
cheat a little so that one arm is
actually performing the movement
slightly more than the other you're
relying on it you might not even notice
it consciously but it can be happening
so what you need to do in this case is
switched to a unilateral movement like
dumbbell presses and then this way you
can't help each arm each arm is
operating independently of the other one
and that way you will fatigue at the
same time or one arm will tire out
quicker and you'll know that that's the
side that needs work and once you build
that symmetry that will improve your
ability to perform the movement
technique number four is to have a
spotter with you now obviously a spotter
is gonna be very helpful because they
can prevent you from dropping the weight
on your head they can give you more
courage and they can spot you through
the movement if you start to struggle
but the other reason that having a
spotter is so important is that they
help you to lift more because you want
to perform when you have someone else in
the room you cut off my shoulders well
your what if you're gonna stand up with
me on your shoulder that's what I'm
going to do what you're feeling
something we're doing you can see I'm
adding the barbell and doing squat place
then consciously you will perform better
studies show that our one rep max does
increase when we're being observed we've
reduced assumably more hormones and
neurotransmitters that tell our bodies
this is an important opportunity to
perform and therefore we can engage more
muscle fiber so if you're struggling to
perform your one rep max create an
audience get everyone in the gym gather
round
watch me lift this crazy weight and you
might look like a fool if you drop it on
yourself but you'll probably be stronger
than you ever would be before and this
is actually a really interesting area of
study and certainly something I'll be
returning to in a future video because
when you have an observer it actually
increases your performance across the
board it can help to improve our social
awareness our verbal fluency our quick
thinking our creativity our memory
and I see this myself when I'm talking
to you on camera here I struggle over my
words sometimes stumble it's normal I
have to go back and edit when you're
talking to someone and they're there you
can just find the words and flow and you
speak so much better so there's
obviously something going on here and
you can use it to surpass your
limitations in the gym another tip is to
use supplements and this can make a big
difference sometimes some people get a
lot of benefit from using something like
a pre-workout personally I don't find
that helps I go or jittery actually and
it makes me anxious so instead you said
that my creatine creatine will increase
the amount of energy available to your
muscles by allowing them to recycle ATP
and even if it doesn't improve your one
rep max it can certainly improve your
endurance and help you to pump out more
reps if that's what you're aiming to
improve and finally take a break take a
week off or even two weeks off because
often we're training in this fatigued
state or this suboptimal state we don't
even realize it even if you have a few
days to recover there's probably still
underlying damage you're probably a
little bit nervous system fatigued you
might have an underlying cold or illness
and just taking that time off and then
coming back allows your body a chance to
recover so that you're coming back to
that attempt at your very peak
performance and at the same time this is
when the muscles grow often if I come
back to the gym after a week off I find
out my muscles look bigger which doesn't
seem to make any sense but of course
it's because I'm recovering I'm building
up protein doing rest um more anabolic
and that gives my body a chance to say
let's consolidate all this hard work so
hope some of these tips help I hope they
help you to smash those limits to break
through those boundaries and to go even
further beyond if they did then please
leave a like share the video around
comment down below and let me know what
techniques you use to bust in your
plateaus and stay tuned for more like
this as well as videos on brain training
productivity working online nootropics
Fitness athletics all that usual stuff
so if that sounds good then thanks a ton
for watching I'll see you next time and
bye for now
Oh in case I don't see you before just
want to say a very happy Christmas and
have a fantastic new year and the best
2018 I'll try and upload a few videos
intermittently over the holiday period
but of course you know life gets in the
way we'll see what happens but I'll be
back in the new year with plenty more
content and I hope you have a great one
until then and thank you so much for
your support and for getting behind this
channel have a great one and I'll see
you then